den Millionen Deutsche kämpfen schon
seit Monaten mit viel zu hohen
Gaspreisen aber jetzt jetzt liegen
endlich konkrete Vorschläge auf dem
Tisch jetzt hat die Expertenkommission
der Bundesregierung ihr Konzept
präsentiert tja aber wie viel Geld
konkret bringt den deutschen diese
gaspreisbremse
96 Milliarden Euro schwer die
gaspreisbremse für Deutschland ihr Ziel
Entlastung der Plan der Staat soll
kurzfristig die Gasrechnung übernehmen
und mittelfristig die Gaspreise drücken
das ganze soll in zwei Stufen passieren
Stufe 1 für Dezember übernimmt der Staat
die Gasrechnungen aller Deutschen in der
Hoffnung die hohen Abschläge für Januar
und Februar 2023 teilweise kompensieren
zu können diese Einmalzahlungen dient
als finanzielle Brücke bis zur regulären
Einführung der gaspreisbremse heißt es
im Papier der Kommission für alle
deutschen heißt es also weiterhin sparen
wo es nur geht und im Zweifel den dicken
Pulli rausholen relativ einfach es
bleibt bei dem alten Ratschlag du musst
so viel sparen wie geht weil für
November für Januar und für Februar
musst du ja einfach komplett das
bezahlen das heißt je weniger Gas du
brauchst sie weniger Fernwärme du
brauchst desto weniger musst du bezahlen
können Mieter wegen der hohen Belastung
ihre Miete nicht zahlen dann greift der
Staat mit helfen auch hier ein Stufe 2
in einem zweiten Schritt sollen ab März
2023 bis April 2024 bei 80% eines
geschätzten grundkontingents die Preise
auf 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde gedeckelt
werden für den Verbrauch darüber müssten
die Bürger wieder vollständig zum
regulären Gaspreis selbstaufkommen doch
was plant der Staat für Menschen die
kein Gas verwenden auch für
Fernwärmekunden kommt die Preisbremse
hier will der Staat einen Bruttopreis
von 9,5 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
Fernwärme garantieren Menschen die mit
Öl heizen gehen vorerst leer aus sie
bekommen erstmal gar nichts die
Kommission sagt die Preise für Öl sind
auch gestiegen aber die sind bei weitem
nicht so stark gestiegen wie die Preise
für Gas also das was die ab 20 also ab
nächsten März voraussetzen als Preis für
Privatleute bedeutet ungefähr eine
Verdoppelung des Preises gegenüber 2021
das ist das was viele Leute beim Öl
heute auch haben eine Entwicklung in
ihres Preises manche haben auch schon
mehr aber das ist das wovon man
ausgeruten eben keine für vier oder
fünffachung ist die bei Gas durchaus für
Kunden im Augenblick gibt was bedeutet
die gaspreisbremse also konkret für die
deutschen das Verbraucherportal Verivox
hat ausgerechnet wie hoch die Entlastung
für die Bürger durch eine Gas- und
strompreisbremse ausfällt eine
vierköpfige Familie mit zwei Kindern in
einem Reihenhaus würde mit einem
Verbrauch von 20.000 Kilowattstunden
durch den gaspreisdeckel um die
1.366 Euro pro Jahr entlastet werden ein
Singlehaushalt mit einem Verbrauch von
5000 Kilowattstunden spart um die 340
Euro jetzt müssen nur noch Kanzler
Scholz und der Bundestag dem Hilfspaket
zustimmen
die Energiepreise steigen also immer
weiter das Gas wird immer teurer Wohnung
zu heizen es wird tatsächlich zum puren
Luxus na dann ziehen Sie sich doch
einfach ein Pulli an tja und wenn der
Strom dann ausfällt einfach Kerzen und
Streichhölzer rausholen ja so oder so
ähnlich klingen die Tipps von Wolfgang
Schäuble dem ehemaligen
Bundestagspräsidenten ja das sagt er zur
aktuellen Energiekrise haben wir noch
mal rein
das Entscheidende ist dass die Menschen
das Gefühl haben müssen es geht fair zu
es wird den geholfen die es wirklich
brauchen man muss den Menschen schon
sagen ja das wird schwierig und dann
muss man eben sagen was geht und was
nicht geht man kann den Menschen nicht
ersparen dass die Energie sehr viel
teurer wird aber man kann natürlich
sagen gut die die das nicht mehr
schaffen können
den wird geholfen wir empfinden sie das
nach all den Jahrzehnten Wohlstand dass
wir über Blackouts sprechen und über
kalte Wohnungen das ist nicht
selbstverständlich es ist doch gut und
dann sieht man halt ein Pullover an und
wenn man den zweiten Pullover anzieht
dann geht es auch Strom ist nicht mehr
selbstverständlich das Licht Schrauben
ist schon selbstverständlich aber es
kann auch mal ausfallen ja deswegen hat
man den Zweifel auch ein paar Kerzen und
ein paar Streichhölzer zu Hause und dann
ist natürlich wichtig dass man weiß wo
die sind falls es mal dunkel wird im
Dunkeln suchen ist auch schwierig
Kerzen und Pullover über diesen
Kommentar wollen wir natürlich reden bei
uns im Studio ist Ralf Schuler Leiter
der parlamentsredaktion schönen guten
Morgen Ralf also wie sieht's denn bei
Dir aus ab wie viel Grad ziehst du jetzt
den ersten von den zweiten Pullover an
mit dem Pullover ist es ein bisschen ein
Problem ich habe keine ich trage keine
Pullover ich mag das nicht das ist aber
eine ganz persönliche Geschichte ich
habe ein Holzofen und würde dann einen
schalt drauflegen
das kann aber jetzt nicht die Lösung
sein und so lapidar wie der ehemalige
Bundestags Präsident das jetzt hier
macht mein Gott auch ob der Strom
ausfällt wo sind die Kerzen so eine
trauliche
kriegsgemeinschaft oder sowas das ist
schon ein bisschen seltsamer Ton den er
da anschlägt wir kennen Wolfgang
Schäuble er hat immer so eine seltsame
Balance zwischen gegen den stachelöcken
dann aber auch wieder bisschen
staatstragend zu sein jetzt wollte er
offensichtlich staatstragend sein Leute
wenn es mal hart kommt dann nicht gleich
verzagen ich verstehe die Botschaft aber
so lapidar kann man es nicht machen und
es gibt seit einiger Zeit so ein ganz
seltsame Tendenz von Spitzenpolitikern
irgendwie Tipps fürs das Leben zu geben
das begann mit Angela Merkel die sagte
ja wenn es kühl ist im Klassenzimmer bei
Corona dann kann man halt Kniebeugen
machen oder sowas das ist einfach
unpassend oder
garchlappen haben wir gehört Georg sagte
dann irgendwann mal frieren für den für
den Frieden oder frieren für die
Freiheit sorry es gibt einen
Privatbereich da hat die Politik nicht
rein zu regieren schon gar nicht die
Bundespolitik aus aus Berlin das wirkt
einfach unangemessen jeder weiß schon
was er zu tun hat wenn ihm fröstelt aber
nicht solche Tipps bitte also wer die
das Resultat bessere Politik statt doofe
Kommentare oder nun ist es ja diese
ganze Energiekrise schon eine ein
Ergebnis von verfehlter Politik das muss
man ganz klar so sagen dann kommt immer
die Begründung ja aber wer hätte den
Krieg vorhersehen können das hat keiner
trotzdem ist es gute Politik aller
Verantwortlichen Nationen sich nicht
einseitig von einem Energieträger und
einem Land abhängig zu machen das hat
man aus mutwillig tatsächlich ich bin ja
lange genug dabei gewesen Mut will ich
in den Wind geschlagen und hat jetzt die
Quittung bekommen aber es geht jetzt
nicht um irgendwie alte Rechnung es geht
einfach darum dass man sagt leute es
wird ernst und natürlich tun wir alles
um die Energieversorgung zu sichern die
Energieversorgung ist nicht einfach
irgendwie eine Kerze oder ein
Streichholz die Energieversorgung ist
die Lebensader der westlichen
Wohlstandsgesellschaften das muss man
sich einfach immer wieder klar machen
und ein stromausfallenden Blackout
bedeutet nicht nur dass es Licht aus ist
sondern es ist nicht es ist die Heizung
aus es ist der Geldautomat es ist die
Tankstelle es ist die Kommunikation es
ist alles das wir sind eine hoch
vernetzte Gesellschaft und dann so Lapid
darüber hinwegzugehen hey hole den
Pullunder raus machen das hier ein
gemütlicher lagerfeuerabend das ist der
Sache nicht angemessen wir brauchen
keine polyempfehlungen sagt Ralf Schuler
danke schön gerne
[Musik]